You're going to be resentful and bitter
in many situations because you don't get
what you want and if you watch that
resentment,
bitterness,
clc,
that it produces fantasies that can be
unbelievably dark and that can be very
frightening and you might not want to
admit to yourself that you're actually
capable of having fantasies like that or
impulses of like that or aggressive
feelings like that.
But the thing is is that if those
aggressive feelings and impulses and
fantasies are integrated into your
character,
it's like you're opening up a dialogue
with a part of yourself that can be very
forceful and strong and dangerous,
and it's really useful to be dangerous
because if you can,
if you can be dangerous,
you often don't have to be,
and it's often weak.
People,
for example,
it's weak men generally speaking,
who rape.
You know that that's a very,
very common occurrence and that's a
violent act,
but it's born out of weakness,
not out of strength.
That's for sure.
And so anyways,
you attend to your resentment honestly,
and you observe yourself and what you're
actually like.
You got to pay attention as if you don't
know yourself as if you might harbor
hidden devils and then maybe they'll
emerge.
Now.
Young also felt that sort of embedded
inside the shower where the contra
sexual tendencies and so for example,
sometimes you see people who are well
developed men let's say,
and we can.
We can also talk about women in this
regard.
Men who've integrated their shadow often
also develop a kind of peculiar grace
that would be a consequence of not only
allowing their aggressive side to step
forward,
but also their feminine in Compassionate
side that might,
that they may have kept squelched
because of embarrassment about it or
because they'd been harassed for being
weak or any number of things so,
but the practical approach for
developing your shadow,
I would say is to contemplate and
consider your resentment and notice what
it says and because your resentment will
also tell you what you have to say.
You know,
so look,
look at what happened at Google this
weekend.
You know,
James Damore wrote that memo and you can
imagine he was pretty angry and perhaps
even somewhat resentful at having to
attend that diversity seminar,
and I'm really just using this as an
example,
but what he did was decide that that
meant that he had something that he had
to say and then look at the consequences
of that.
Man.
It's an absolutely unbelievable and so
you know,
if you're feeling oppressed at work or
you're oppressed in your life or or you
know where you're expressing yourself,
then you got to notice that you're
feeling oppressed.
Then you have to notice that you're
feeling resentful,
resentful,
and angry and bitter and maybe even like
Cain in the story of Cain and Abel
because Cain is sort of the archetype of
bitter man.
And then you have to decide what it is
that you need to do in order to remove
from yourself that bitterness.
And that's usually means that there's
something that you have to say and then
you have to say it because you're soul
depends on it.
And not only does your soul depend on
it.
I would say the fate of the world
depends on it because you know you might
be wrong and then you should be
straightened out.
Maybe you're just being windy and you
have to talk to somebody about that,
but it may be that you're actually
detecting something wrong.
Some tyranny that's directed towards you
and other people,
and it's like your moral obligation to
speak up about it.